hi there steve kaufman here
just finishing off on apple
[Music]
um today i want to share with you
some of the things that i do at link how
i learn my languages
uh remember if you enjoy my videos
please subscribe
uh click on the
tap on the bell here or click on it in
order to get notifications and come and
join us at link
so obviously if i share what i do how i
learn languages i'm going to refer to
link because that's where i learn
languages i also happen to think it's
very useful i put a lot of my
you know time and life into it over the
last 15 years i believe in it i think
it's good i want to share it with other
people
hi just wanted to interrupt to update
you on my statistics in the 90 day
challenge finished month 2 so i'm
showing you statistics for the whole
month of october my goal is to get to
20 000 known words which means i need to
have 2 000 new known words each month i
got pretty close in the month of october
you'll see how i do that in the video
you'll see how the words in my
transcripts of my algeria al jazeera
podcasts
are more and more white and fewer and
fewer words are yellow or blue
and i understand them a little better
but it's a long road
and i think it's a good thing to to
share what we're doing in in learning
languages
uh that's one of the things uh in my
presentation at the polyglot conference
i was sharing some of the things that i
did how i collect
um content to learn from
and i have indicated they would be fun
you know as we're all hunkered down and
covet
and particularly older people who may be
at loose ends or you know i'm lucky i
have a fairly large house and i can go
to the golf course but some people don't
have that opportunity like the great
thing about the golf course is that it's
it's an opportunity to be social without
being in a room with someone so we meet
all kinds of different people some of
whom we know some we don't know and it's
social and we play i play very poor golf
but
but many people don't have that so i
thought it would be fun to get together
and share our experiences in language
learning and maybe encourage some
people including seniors to
get more active in learning languages by
the way next tuesday we're going to do a
live stream in espanol
with shelby on the different things that
we do on links so that'll be live
streamed on tuesday 10 o'clock i think
vancouver or pacific standard time
so it's fun to share what we do
um i by the way i contacted her we one
of the people in our office contacted a
seniors group here
in vancouver to suggest that we could do
a live stream with seniors and talk
about language learning and
their comment was well is your
organization for profit
uh you're not allowed to talk about any
for-profit
uh thing that you're doing
so i said that's okay don't worry about
it we needn't bother
uh having the session because if i'm
gonna talk about language learning i'm
gonna talk about a link because that's
what i do anyway so with that what do i
two things that i've been doing recently
that may be of interest to you
one is because i'm in this um
you know 90 day challenge i'm sort of
under under the gun i want to increase
my known words total and every week i do
a little summary of my statistics
and you'll see that my known words total
is growing
but i have two major activities which
i'm going to share with you now
i did a a sort of a screen share on my
ipad for whatever reason
i tried to explain what i was doing and
that sound was not recorded so you'll
just see sort of silently what i do
but the sound that did come through was
the sound that comes from the ipad so
i'm going to show two things i'm going
to show first of all
how i go to the vocabulary section
select status three words
have them in order of importance so that
the most frequent ones show up first and
then i go through there and discover
that in fact
i know a minute i have 50 000 saved
links so status three i don't know how
many but there are thousands of words
that i have moved to status three
because
either when i'm reading or whatever and
i feel i know it a little better now and
i kind of shoved it along the status
three so i get go into the vocab section
i
there's like 45 pages
of status three words
and um
either i start at the top which is the
most freq you know the highest frequency
ones or sometimes i'll just select page
16 of 45 and start going through there
and i normally will find lots of words
that i know already and so i go through
there every day try to get
a hundred of them so if i can keep doing
that then i'm gonna move my known words
total to
uh that twenty thousand number i have
the feeling that with twenty 000
that will kind of be a bit of a
milestone in terms of my comprehension
comprehension of these uh podcasts that
i get from al jazeera so i will show you
how i do that
and uh so that'll be one thing so you
i've explained you know what you are
going to see it's going to be me at the
vocabulary page
uh ticking off moving some first of all
selecting for status three words you'll
see that
and
then uh
deciding that i know this word and
moving it to known which is a tick mark
i do this you know i'm not too tough on
myself
if i kind of think i know it or i would
recognize it in context i move it to no
because
when i'm reading through texts at link
these will now show up as white they
won't be shaded yellow and they
certainly won't be blue
if i find that i don't know them again i
can move them back
but i like it when i get into my texts
and i see a few yellow words
very few blue words
gives me that sense that i'm getting
somewhere and but yeah if i find in fact
i don't know the word i move it back i
don't demand of myself that i'm able to
remember them and use them
because again my attitude is if i can
achieve a good level of comprehension so
that i can just listen to podcasts and
listen to arabic and i'm just listening
all the time and understanding the
speaking will come as i speak more
but
i don't need to beat myself up on what
does it mean to know a word if i think i
kind of know that in context good enough
i give myself credit for the word it
also nice it's nice to sort of bump up
your statistics gives you the sense
you're achieving something so that's
that now the second thing that i do
is and and this gets back to a number of
people have pointed out that it's
sometimes useful to listen to the target
language and read in your own language
uh i did some of that when i was
learning czech and i would listen to the
good soldier schweich
schweik
in czech and try and read it in english
but very soon you fall behind
and there's too many words that you
don't know
so you're kind of able to follow along
while listening to the target language
and reading but there's a lot of words
that you miss
so what i find really useful now
is that um if i get the transcript so i
get my mp3 file of the aljazeera which i
am unable to extract but my
assistant in
morocco does that for me and every week
she sends me three
mp3 files
i put those mp3 files on to
happyscribe.com
i select show date stamps when i have
them printed out the transcripts
with the date stamps
i have
uh incen and i have to import them as as
an ebook into link you have to import it
as an ebook i should have perhaps shown
that but nevertheless you have to import
it as an e-book but what i'm going to
show you is how in sentence mode i'm
able to hear the natural voice of each
sentence some sentences are short some
sentences are longer so i'm going to
show you two segments here one is a
short sentence where there are no blue
words another one is a longer segment
and i won't go through the whole thing
but you can hear the natural voice of
the podcast
uh i can then go back over the words
that i'm still trying to learn the
yellow words or the blue words if i'm
going to convert blue words and then i
hear the text to speech and people have
commented before that the text to speech
is often not as accurate as the natural
voice
but that's why it's so nice to hear
the natural voice voice for these
segments in sentence mode but you have
to get the transcript with date stamps
which is the case if i get them on a
happy transcribe i ask to show the date
stamps
i import them as an ebook that's how you
have to import them otherwise the date
stamps disappear
if you bring something in from youtube
it is also a date stand and there again
you can look at it in sentence mode if
you bring something in from youtube
uh into link
then you actually see the video
as well as the audio for each
uh for each sentence when you go to
listen away from the
iphone or ipad or whatever then of
course you're listening to the whole
text
okay so that was just a little bit of a
oh yeah i should let you listen to that
so i'll put that on now you can we'll
just close out with that you can see
what i'm doing when i'm studying in
sentence mode
these podcast transcripts
foreign
foreign
i just noticed that the last word the
blue word that i
clicked on was in fact uh not an it was
like two words squished together so
some of you who know arabic might have
noticed that
uh occasionally the happy scribe makes a
mistake very very seldom but it happens
it's not enough to disturb me and i
think it's important to always have an
attitude in learning languages that we
are going to come across mistakes native
speakers make mistakes
people criticize the text-to-speech
which makes mistakes but it all helps
nevertheless we don't need perfection
so
i thought i'd just jump in there and
mention that in case i started getting
comments saying that that was a squished
word okay anyway
don't go for perfection just go for
enjoyment and improvement
bye for now
[Music]
you